AARON KARP: Generic Selectors.
We have a new Generic
Selector type.
It replaces the Service Specific
Selectors that you've
been using before.
So whereas, say, Campaign
Service had its own selector
type, now we have one single
selector object that is used
across services.
Now the biggest difference you
guys will notice immediately
is that instead of selecting
all of the fields for an
object at once, you now have
to specify the individual
field that you want back.
This also provides for powerful
filtering and storing
options within your selectors.
So Generic Selectors return
objects specific to the
service that they're
used with.
What does that mean?
It means that you can use the
same selector objects on the
Campaign Service, that you can
use on the AdGroup AdService
or the AdGroup service.
And it will automatically return
a list of AdGroups, or
campaigns, or ads, or whatever
it is that you're using it in
conjunction with.
You could also do
this previously.
But we've maintained the stash
retrieval functionality for
specific date ranges, request
ordering, and request paging.
These are the services that are
moving to Generic Selectors.
I'm sure you guys will recognize
quite a few that you
use selectors on yourselves.
So this whole list is available
through the
documentation.
So fields can be either
selectable,
filterable, or neither.
These are the fields
of an object.
So if it's selectable, it means
that it can be retrieved
with a Selector via
a get operation.
So that's something like
the campaign ID.
Filterable means values can be
filtered using a Predicate
within a Selector.
Not all fields fit into
both categories.
Here for the AdGroup object,
you have the AdGroup ID.
It says that it is Filterable
and Selectable.
The status is also Filterable
So what does the new Selector
object look like?
It would have the following
five fields.
The fields field, which
is the list of fields
that you want to select.
This is the one required
field, here.
The predicate.
This is what you use
for filtering.
The date range for stats
that you want.
The ordering--
fields to sort off.
You can sort on multiple
fields, as
well as the sort order.
So you can do campaign name
ascending, and then by click,
for example.
Paging has rules for paginating
of the results.
So, for example, we want to get
these four fields back for
any Campaign Object.
Then we will use the
following Selector.
Set the field as an array
of strings, these four.
And then this Selector could
be used as a get operation
just as it is.
Remember, I've said that the
fields field is the only
required property you have
to set on the Selector.
So if you only want to retrieve
a campaign with a
specific ID, or you only want
to retrieve a campaign with
more than 200 clicks over a
specific date range, you can
do all of these quite powerful
things using predicates.
Here we say, for this predicate
object, we're
setting the field that we
want filter on as ID.
We're setting the operator
as in, so the ID is in
this array of values.
And then we add that predicate
to our Selector Object.
So here we're going to sort by
two different properties.
First by name ascending and then
by start date descending.
Again, pretty easy.
We create our order by objects
and set the field names to
name and start date.
We set the order here to
descending, Because we don't
need to put the defaults
for the other one.
Paging works quite similarly
to how it
did in the old version.
So we set our start index.
We set the number of
results we want.
Pretty straightforward, right?
Good, now let's talk about
selecting Stats.
So you use the Selector
dateRange to specify the Stats
fields that you want returned.
So if you are selecting
the following fields--
Id, Text, Clicks,
Ctr, and Cost--
and if we want to filter where
the Clicks are greater than
200, then you'd use the
following Selector.
Here we're setting the fields
that we want back.
And we're setting the
date range specified
in the strings above.
Then we're adding a predicate.
We're saying that we want to
filter on fields, where the
value is greater than 200.
So the list of available
predicate
operators is pretty big.
It will be the full list
in the documentation.
So the Response Objects is the
same type that you got back in
previous versions.
If you're using Generic
Selectors for the
CampaignService, you get
back a Campaign Object.
Using them for the AdGroup
service, you
get an AdGroup back.
Now one thing to note is that
you may get null values back
for fields that you don't
request. So if your code is
currently indiscriminately
accessing fields on the
objects, you might need to add
in some null checking.
An easy way to do the migration
is just check which
fields you need in your existing
code, and then build
your Selector to match that.
So what are some
best practices?
First of all, specify only the
fields you actually want.
Don't try to imitate the Select
Star functionality of
the previous version.
This defeats the purpose.
And you'll always be
playing catchup as
we modify the objects.
These are the two errors you
will most commonly see with
Generic Selectors--
the invalid field name and the
invalid predicate field name--
which are pretty
self-explanatory.
You give us a string that we
don't know how to handle,
we'll give you back
this error.
And then, use Generic Selectors
to add new and
interesting functionality.
So, get criteria with clicks
greater than 200 and ctr of
less than 2.0 last week.
So if you don't have all of the
data for a given account
cached in your system, you can
select it all on the fly,
based on your user's needs
of your application.
So we have put together a
Selector Migration Guide.
It includes both a mapping of
the fields in each object to
their selector names, if you
will, selector field names.
And it also includes some sample
code and PHP that shows
roughly what I've put up
on the board today.
Thank you very much.